D'abord, si vous regardez la distribution du patrimoine,
c'est-à-dire la part du patrimoine total détenue par les 10 % les plus riches,
vous observez la même distribution
entre l'Europe et les USA que celle que nous avions
avant pour les revenus.
La concentration de patrimoine était plus élevée
en Europe qu'aux USA il y a un siècle,
et aujourd'hui c'est le contraire.
Mais deux autres choses apparaissent :
primo, la distribution du patrimoine est toujours plus inégale
que celle des revenus.
Rappelez-vous, pour la distribution des revenus
la part attribuée aux 10% les plus riches
était de 30 à 50% du revenu total, tandis que pour la distribution du patrimoine
cette part est toujours comprise entre 60 et 90% du patrimoine total.
C'est donc le premier fait
et il est décisif pour la suite.
La concentration du patrimoine
est bien supérieure à celle des revenus.
Le deuxième fait est l'augmentation
des différences dans la distribution des richesses
dans les dernières décennies, à un niveau qui reste inférieur à 1910.
Aujourd'hui la distribution du patrimoine est toujours très inégale
avec 60 à 70% du patrimoine pour les 10% les plus riches,
mais la bonne nouvelle est que c'est mieux qu'il y a un siècle,
où 90% du patrimoine en Europe était aux mains de 10% de la population.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons
ce que j'appelle les « 40% du milieu »,
ceux qui ne sont ni les 10% les plus riches
ni dans les 50% les moins riches,
ceux que l'on peut appeler la « classe moyenne »,
qui possède 20 à 30%
du patrimoine national total,
alors que cette catégorie était pauvre, il y a 100 ans,
quand il n'y avait pour ainsi dire pas de classe moyenne.
C'est un changement important
et il est intéressant de constater que la distribution du patrimoine
n'est pas revenue à son niveau d'avant la 1ère Guerre Mondiale,
alors que c'est le cas pour la distribution du patrimoine.
Voici la valeur de la richesse venant des revenus,
et on observe, particulièrement en Europe,
qu'on revient quasiment à des niveaux d'avant la Première Guerre Mondiale.
On a donc deux parties distinctes de la même histoire.
La première a à voir
avec la quantité de patrimoine que nous épargnons
et cela n'a rien de mauvais en soi,
d'accumuler énormément de richesses,
surtout si elles sont bien réparties et peu concentrées.
Concentrons-nous sur l'évolution, sur le long terme,
de la distribution du patrimoine
et sur ce qui risque d'arriver dans le futur.
Comment expliquer que, jusqu'en 1914,
l'inégalité de répartition du patrimoine ait été aussi forte,
et ait pu progresser à des niveaux encore plus élevés ?
Quelles conclusions peut-on en tirer pour le futur ?
Passons maintenant aux explications et aux hypothèses pour le futur.
J'aimerais d'abord souligner
que le meilleur modèle pour expliquer
pourquoi les patrimoines sont plus concentrés que les revenus
est sans doute un modèle dynastique
où les individus réfléchissent à long terme
et accumulent du patrimoine pour toutes sortes de raisons.
Si les gens n'accumulaient ce patrimoine que
pour en profiter au cours de leur vie
pour pouvoir consommer alors une fois âgées,
la distribution du patrimoine
devrait alors etre plus ou moins en ligne avec la distribution des revenus.
Il est difficile d'expliquer en quoi
la distribution du patrimoine est plus inégale
que celle des revenus avec un tel modèle.
On doit donc envisager un scénario où
les gens accumulent du patrimoine pour d'autres raisons.
Typiquement, ils veulent transmettre
leur patrimoine à la génération suivante, à leurs enfants,
ou bien ils veulent accumuler ce patrimoine
pour le prestige, ou le pouvoir qu'il procure.
Il y a donc d'autres raisons que le cycle de la vie pour pousser
à accumuler du patrimoine et expliquer ces chiffres.
Dans un grand nombre de modèles dynamiques d'accumulation de patrimoine
comprenant la motivation dynastique pour justifier l'accumulation,
on trouve toutes sortes de chocs aléatoires multiplicatifs.
Par exemple, certaines familles ont beaucoup d'enfants,
ce qui divise le patrimoine total.
D'autres familles ont moins d'enfants.
Il y a aussi des baisses de rendement.
Certaines familles font d'énormes profits,
d'autres de mauvais investissements.
Le processus de création de richesses connaît ainsi
des aléas dûs à ces chocs.
Certains montent dans la hiérarchie, d'autres reculent.
Le point important est que dans un tel modèle,
et pour une répartition donnée de tels chocs,
le niveau d'équilibre
de la distribution de richesse est une fonction croissante de r - g.
Intuitivement, la raison pour laquelle
la différence entre le rendement du patrimoine
et la croissance est si importante
est que la distribution du patrimoine de départ
s'est amplifiée rapidement
à cause d'une différence croissante entre r et g.
Prenons un exemple simple,
avec un r de 5% et un g de 1%, les détenteurs de patrimoine
ne doivent réinvestir que 20% de leurs revenus de capital
pour s'assurer que leur patrimoine augmente aussi vite
que l'économie.
Il est donc plus facile de construire et perpétuer
d'énormes fortunes, car dans un scénario sans taxe,
vous pouvez en consommer 80% et n'en réinvestir que 20%.
Bien sûr certaines familles consommeront plus,
d'autres moins, ce qui entraîne une variation de la distribution,
mais en moyenne, il leur suffit de réinvestir 20%
pour maintenir les inégalités de patrimoines.
Il ne faut pas être supris par le fait que
r peut rester indéfiniment supérieur à g
car c'est ce qui s'est passé
durant la plus grande part de notre histoire
et c'était assez évident pour tout le monde,
simplement car la croissance est restée quasiment nulle
durant la majeure partie de l'histoire.
La croissance était de l'ordre de 0,1, 0,2 ou 0,3%,
avec une faible croissance démographique et une faible productivité par habitant,
alors que le taux de rendement du capital restait bien sûr supérieur à 0.
Dans le cas des terres,
qui étaient la forme classique de capital dans les sociétés préindustrielles,
le rendement était typiquement de 5%.
Quiconque a lu Jane Austen sait ça.
Si vous vouliez 1000 livres de revenus annuels,
il vous fallait un capital
de 20 000 livres de sorte que
5% de 20 000 vous donnent 1 000 en retour.
D'une certaine manière,
c'était un des fondements de la société,
car le fait que r soit supérieur à g
permettait aux détenteurs de capitaux et de patrimoine
de vivre des revenus de leurs capitaux
et de faire autre chose de leurs vies,
que de se battre quotidiennement pour survivre.
En fait, une des conclusions principales
de mes recherches historiques est que
la croissance industrielle moderne
n'a étonnamment pas changé grand chose à cette situation.
Bien sûr, le taux de croissance qui a suivi la Révolution Industrielle
a augmenté, passant de 0 à 1 ou 2%, mais dans le même temps,
le taux de rendement du capital a également augmenté
de telle sorte que l'écart entre les deux
n'a pas fondamentalement changé.
On a pu observer durant le 20ème siècle une combinaison inédite d'événements.
D'abord, un taux de rendement faible
dû aux chocs qu'ont été les deux guerres mondiales,
la destruction de la croissance, l'inflation,
ou faillites lors de la Grande Dépression,
tout cela a conduit à un taux
de rendement des patrimoines privés à un niveau inhabituellement bas
entre 1914 et 1945.
Ensuite, après la guerre, on a connu
une croissance inhabituellement forte,
due, entre autre, à la reconstruction.
L' Allemagne, la France, le Japon
ont connu des taux de croissance de 5% entre 1950 et 1980,
grâce à la reconstruction,
et aussi à une forte croissance démographique,
le fameux « Baby Boom ».
Mais cela ne devrait pas durer très longtemps,
la croissance démographique devrait baisser dans le futur,
et les meilleurs scénarios prévoient une croissance à long terme
plus proche de 1 à 2% que de 4 ou 5%.
En examinant ces graphiques,
qui sont les meilleures estimations en notre possession
sur la croissance du PIB mondial et le rendement du capital,
le rendement moyen du capital,
on remarque un taux de croissance très faible sur des longues durées,
bien en dessous du rendement du capital
puis au cours du 20ème siècle
une croissance démographique exceptionnelle après 1945,
et l'effet de la reconstruction,
qui ont réduit l'écart entre
taux de croissance (g) et de rendement (r).
J'utilise ici les projections démographiques des Nations-Unies,
qui sont bien sûr incertaines.
Nous pourrions très bien avoir beaucoup d'enfants dans le futur
ce qui augmenterait le taux de croissance,
mais aujourd'hui
ce sont les meilleures projections dont nous disposons,
et cela ralentira la croissance
et poussera l'écart avec le taux de retour sur investissement à la hausse.
L'autre événement inhabituel qui a eu lieu
au 20ème siècle a été, comme je l'ai souligné,
la destruction du capital et sa taxation,
ce que vous voyez est donc un rendement avant taxation.
Voici donc ce même rendement du capital après taxation,
et après sa destruction,
et c'est la raison qui a conduit à un rendement moyen de capital
après taxes et destruction,
plus faible que la croissance pendant une longue période.
Mais sans cette destruction,
sans la taxation, cela n'aurait jamais eu lieu.
Il faut bien voir que cet écart entre
le taux de rendement du capital et la croissance
dépend de nombreux facteurs très difficiles à prédire :
la technologie et le développement de techniques
à forte intensité capitalistique.
Aujourd'hui, les secteurs de l'économie à plus forte intensité capitalistique
sont l'immobilier, le logement et l'énergie,
mais dans l'avenir nous pourrions voir plus de robots dans d'autres secteurs,
ce qui augmenterait de facto la part du stock de capital dans ces secteurs.
Bien sûr, on en est encore loin,
et pour l'instant, ce qui se passe dans l'immobilier et l'énergie
est bien plus important pour la valorisation des entreprises.
L'autre facteur important est qu'il existe
des effets d'échelle dans la gestion de portefeuilles
associés à une complexité financière, une dérégulation de la finance,
qui assurent plus facilement des rendements importants
pour un portefeuille étendu,
et cela semble particulièrement le cas pour les milliardaires
ou les fonds de pension.
Pour vous donner un exemple,
si l'on regarde le classement Forbes des milliardaires
sur la période 1987-2013,
on s'aperçoit que les fortunes des personnalités les plus riches
ont crû à raison de 6 ou 7% par an
au dessus de l'inflation,
pendant que le revenu moyen et le patrimoine moyen
ont seulement crû de 2% par an dans le monde.
Et l'on observe le même effet pour les fonds d'investissement universitaires
plus la dotation initiale est grande, plus le rendement sera élevé.
Maintenant, que peut-on faire ?
Avant tout nous avons besoin de plus de transparence financière.
On ne connaît pas suffisamment les dynamiques de la richesse mondiale,
il faut donc plus d'échanges internationaux d'informations bancaires.
Nous avons besoin d'un registre global des patrimoines,
d'une meilleure coordination des politiques fiscales
et même une faible taxation du patrimoine
serait une piste pour produire de l'information
permettant d'adapter nos politiques publiques
à la réalité des faits.
D'une certaine manière,
la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux et l'échange automatique d'informations
nous poussent déjà dans cette direction.
Ceci dit, il existe d'autres manières
de redistribuer les richesses qui peuvent séduire.
D'abord, l'inflation :
il est plus facile d'imprimer des billets que de rédiger un code fiscal,
mais il est parfois difficile de savoir comment utiliser l'argent.
Ce qui pose problème.
L'expropriation a également de quoi séduire,
quand quelqu'un est trop riche, on lui confisque ses biens.
Mais ce n'est pas une méthode très efficace
pour réguler la dynamique des richesses.
La guerre est encore moins efficace,
j'ai donc tendance à préférer la taxation progressive,
mais, évidemment, l'Histoire (Rires)
trouvera de meilleures méthodes,
ce qui impliquera probablement une combinaison de tout ceci.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Thomas Piketty, merci.
J'aimerais vous poser 2 ou 3 questions
parce que votre maîtrise des données m'impressionne, bien sûr,
mais en fait, ce que vous suggérez est que
la concentration croissante du patrimoine est une tendance naturelle du capitalisme,
et si rien n'est fait pour le réguler,
cela pourrait menacer l'ensemble du système.
Vous suggérez donc d'agir et de mettre en place des politiques
pour redistribuer la richesse,
comme celles que nous venons juste de voir :
taxation progressive, etc.
Dans le contexte politique actuel, est-ce réaliste ?
Pensez-vous qu'on puisse vraiment espérer
les voir un jour mises en place ?
T. Piketty : Vous savez, si on remonte assez loin,
l'histoire du revenu, du patrimoine et des taxes, est pleine de surprises.
Je ne suis pas impressionné
par ceux qui savent à l'avance ce qui se passera ou pas.
Il y a un siècle, beaucoup de gens vous auraient dit
que la taxation progressive du revenu ne serait jamais effective
et aujourd'hui elle l'est.
Et même il y a cinq ans de cela,
nombre de gens auraient dit que le secret bancaire
serait éternel en Suisse,
que la Suisse était trop forte pour plier à la pression internationale,
puis soudain, quelques sanctions américaines
contre les banques suisses ont radicalement changé ça
et on se dirige maintenant vers plus de transparence financière.
Je pense qu'il n'est pas très difficile d'améliorer la coordination
des politiques publiques.
Nous aurons bientôt un traité qui concernera la moitié du PIB mondial,
c'est à dire les USA et l'Europe
si cela n'est pas suffisant pour faire des progrès sur la transparence financière
et sur une taxation minimale des profits des multinationales,
que faut-il alors ?
Le problème n'est pas technique.
Je pense qu'on fera des progrès si nous adoptons
une approche plus pragmatique sur ces questions
et des sanctions plus adaptées
envers ceux qui bénéficient de cette opacité.
B. Giussani : Un des arguments contre votre vision
est que l'inégalité économique
n'est pas seulement une caractéristique du capitalisme, mais un de ses moteurs.
Donc si on prend des mesures pour réduire les inégalités,
on risque en même temps de réduire la croissance.
Que leur répondez-vous ?
T. Piketty : En effet, les inégalités ne sont pas un problème en soi.
Elles sont même, d'une manière, utiles pour l'innovation et la croissance
Tout le problème concerne le niveau acceptable.
Si les inégalités deviennent trop extrêmes,
elles ne sont plus utiles pour la croissance
et peuvent devenir néfastes
car elles entraînent la perpétuation d'inégalités dans le temps
et une faible mobilité sociale.
Par exemple, le genre de concentration de richesses qu'on a connue au 19e siècle
et jusqu'à la Première Guerre Mondiale dans chaque pays d'Europe
n'a pas du tout contribué à la croissance.
Ces inégalités ont été brisées
par une série d'événements tragiques et de changements politiques,
et la croissance est revenue.
Les inégalités extrêmes peuvent également être néfastes
pour nos institutions démocratiques
si elles créent des inégalités de représentativité politique
et l'influence de l'argent privé sur la politique américaine
est, je pense, un réel problème aujourd'hui.
Personne n'a donc intérêt à ce qu'on revienne
aux niveaux d'inégalités d'avant 1914.
Le fait que la classe moyenne ait une part normale de la richesse mondiale
n'est pas néfaste pour la croissance.
Au contraire, c'est utile pour des raisons d'équité et d'efficacité.
B. Giussani : Comme je l'ai dit au début, votre livre a été critiqué.
Une part de vos données l'a été.
Certains de vos choix de jeu de données également.
Vous avez été accusé de ne choisir que les données qui vous arrangeaient.
Que répondez-vous ?
T. Piketty : Je suis très content de voir le très large débat
que ce livre a suscité.
C'était un de mes objectifs initiaux.
Si j'ai mis en ligne l'ensemble des données
avec le détail de mes calculs,
c'est pour qu'on puisse avoir un débat ouvert
et transparent sur le sujet.
J'ai répondu point par point à toutes les objections soulevées.
Et si je devais réécrire ce livre,
je conclurais que la montée des inégalités de richesses,
en particulier aux USA, a été plus forte
que celle décrite dans mon livre.
Il y a récemment eu une étude de Saez et Zucman qui démontre
avec de nouvelles données que je n'avais pas lorsque je l'ai écrit
que la concentration de richesses aux USA a crû
encore plus que ce que j'ai écrit.
Et il y aura d'autres données dans le futur.
Certaines iront dans d'autres directions.
Vous savez, chaque semaine nous mettons en ligne
une mise à jour de la base World Top Income
et on continuera à le faire,
en particulier pour les pays émergents,
et j'invite tous ceux qui peuvent à contribuer
à la collecte de ces données.
En fait, je suis assez d'accord pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas assez de transparence dans la dynamique des richesses,
et une bonne manière d'avoir de meilleures données
serait d'avoir une taxe sur le patrimoine
avec au départ un taux faible
pour obtenir un consensus sur l'importance de cette évolution
puis adapter nos politiques en fonction des résultats.
L'impôt est une source d'information
et c'est ce dont nous avons le plus besoin aujourd'hui.
B. Giussani : Merci beaucoup.
T. Piketty : Merci. (Applaudissements)